un geste que port marly aimerait voir se
développer la commune de 6000 habitants
vient de se doter de deux nouvelles
bornes de recharge pour les véhicules
électriques
nous sommes traversés par deux voies à
grande circulation
et avec ce que cela comporte comme
nuisances pollutions sonores évolution
de l'air ça nous conforte évidemment
dans une action et cette action en
faveur des véhicules électriques est
évidemment importante pour nous un
dispositif accessible grâce à un badge à
prendre auprès du syndicat d'énergie des
yvelines plus de 140 bornes seront
installées d'ici la fin de l'année 2009
dans le département
parce que le développement à grande
échelle des bornes électriques comme le
prévoit d'ailleurs la récente le récent
projet de programmation pluriannuelle
d'énergie à l'horizon 2030 ces sept
millions de bornes qui sont pris 10,7
millions de bornes il faudra des
raccordés sur le réseau public
d'électricité et donc ça nécessitera
d'adapter ce réseau le budget global de
l'installation dans le département est
estimé à 1 million d'euros 76 autres
communes sont concernées dont maurepas
et plaisir